a hierarchy of educational
qualifications might look something a
bit like this with elementary or primary
school at the bottom stretching past
degrees and undergraduates to graduates
and PhD level now I'm currently studying
for PhD in atmospheric physics and I
thought it might be interesting to look
at how you go from the bottom of this
ladder to the top run and then
graduating and stepping off of it so
here's how you get a PhD in five easy
steps step number one get yourself a
degree in a relevant subject here's one
I made earlier the key foundation to
doing a PhD is undergraduate study in a
particular subject so I'm studying
atmospheric physics one PhD I did a
degree in physics now most people who go
on to do a PhD will do an undergraduate
a three year course and then a graduate
course like a masters not everybody does
in fact I know ago personally who went
straight on to a PhD after a three-year
BA but most people will do a master's
course now I was a bit different because
I did a four-year undergraduate which
was integrated masters so I have an M
physio a BSc but like I say most people
will do an undergraduate and then a
separate graduate qualification this is
for the UK by the way in the US they
have a different thing like undergrad
and then grad school I don't know
anything about that so many even talk
about the UK system sorry if you were
expecting American stuff it's also worth
mentioning that while some people will
do undergraduate and graduate degrees in
slightly different fields - what they do
their PhD on the vast vast majority will
follow some kind of progression so I did
my undergraduate degree in physics my
master's year of that course the final
year was spent on theoretical and
atmospheric physics and then I moved on
to a PhD in theoretical atmospheric
physics step number two find yourself a
supervisor or a project here's one I
found earlier now this is where things
are a bit different for Humanities and
Sciences I'm a scientist so in the
sciences the way that it worked for me
was I browse through a bunch of projects
that are being offered by different
universities so I applied to a couple of
different universities went through the
list of projects they were offering now
atmospheric physics departments and pick
what I thought was interesting there was
a supervisor associated with those
projects and it was that supervisor that
interviewed me much like an
undergraduate degree but a bit more
focused on the project rather than sort
of me solving problems it was a
discussion about what the project is
going to entail and then the supervisor
who gets fine
say over whether I'm the student that
gets to do that project now in the
sciences that project normally has
funding associated with it so there are
research councils for example like
Newark who found a lot of science PhDs
in the atmospheric sciences and there's
a stipend associated with that so you
don't have to work during your degree in
the humanities things aren't quite as
rosy for some students it's a similar
kind of thing where you apply for a
project but more often than not you have
to get funding together yourself this
isn't something I have a huge amount of
experience with but the gist that I
understand is that you do apply to
research councils it won't be Newark it
will be the equivalent full history or
art or whatever it is you wish to study
then generally you will track down a
supervisor ask them if you can do a
particular project that you've devised
and then there's a interview in a debate
about whether you get to do the project
or not most people will have more than
one supervisor generally one main
supervisor and then like a backup a
secondary supervisor who just kind of
looks at things from afar and gives
advice where necessary but some people
will have a whole team of supervisors
one or many though you do need a
supervisor in order to get a PhD step
number three you must perform some
original research now there are two key
parts of that sentence you must perform
the research and the research must be
original innovative new it's not enough
to simply rehash what somebody else did
in a scientific paper and reframe it you
have to take what other people have done
and expand on what they've done or
suggest the new idea and test it or
maybe show how what people have done in
the past was incorrect and show why and
how it's incorrect ideally then
presenting some new idea about how it is
done instead so in my PhD the research
group that I'm part of we have this
hypothesis which as part of my PhD I
took mathematically framed and I'm in
the middle of testing to see whether the
hypothesis sticks and explains the data
or not so while the idea may not be
original to me it's it's original to the
research group I'm the person that
mathematically formulated it that did
the analysis that presented something
that hadn't been done before psych
though it doesn't actually matter if
you're right or not the important thing
is that you performed original research
it doesn't actually matter if your
hypothesis is correct or incorrect it's
still adding to human knowledge because
in the future people will say well we
know it's not this so it's still a
valuable contribution he tells himself
anticipating that his PhD
is full of things that are wrong step
number four you must then write up this
new innovative research in a PhD thesis
the plural of which incidentally is PhD
theses and I'm in my fourth year and
that's still funny a thesis is basically
the essay to end all essays even if you
choose to stay in academia you will
never write anything like a thesis again
thesis is anything between 120 to well
actually there's no upper limit but
generally like a hundred to 200 maybe
300 pages in that you present the work
that you've done in context so generally
you have a first chapter we introduce
the problem you're looking at you then
have a second chapter which is like a
literature review getting background
about what you're doing and then you
have a couple of chapters explaining
what it is that you've done and then at
the end like any good essay you have a
conclusion and of course a bibliography
the bibliography can be vast I read a
thesis the other day where it was about
20 pages long really quite small text
generally speaking you write the thesis
at the end of your PhD after you've done
a whole bunch of work well actually
that's in an ideal world because most
the time you write bits of your thesis
as you go along which is then completely
scrapped and at the end of your PhD you
kind of rewrite it again and then you're
constantly updating it as you keep doing
more experiments or keep finding new
readings if your humanities student
until it's like some Frankenstein
monster of what you planned and just
bits that you kind of cobbled along
along the way one of your supervisors
key jobs is to make sure that your
thesis is in line with what the
examiner's more on that in a second will
expect from you so your thesis is kind
of like your write-up of everything
you've done over the three to four years
in the UK that you spend on your PhD and
then Step five you defend your thesis in
a PhD diver advisor can be thought of as
the examined end of your PhD but it's
not really like that it's a defense of
what you do you defend your thesis and a
fiver the point of it is to make sure
that the work that you've done is up to
scratch that you completed the work and
you can answer questions about it and
that you basically haven't plagiarized
it from somewhere else the way that this
is done is that you have two examiner's
normally a internal and an external
examiner now the internal examiner is
someone from your University who isn't a
specialist in your field who's basically
there to make sure that you and the
external examiner play by the rules of
your particular University while the
external examiner is an
expert in your field like a
laser-focused person who has done
exactly what you've been doing in your
PhD for their entire academic career
normally this means this person is
terrifying to you and it's this person's
job to read your thesis and go through
it with a toothpick and make sure they
understand every figure every equation
every page and then talk to you about it
and ask you why you make decisions why
you did certain things why you didn't do
certain things the Viper can be kind of
a protracted affair generally there a
couple of hours long and it's just three
of you in a room together but they can
be anything up to a whole day long
somewhat depressingly the two examiner's
are basically the only people that will
ever read your thesis in its entirety
apart from maybe your supervisor you
have a good supervisor at the end of the
Bible you then walk away and some time
later you find out about your verdict
you either fail and I'd like to point
out that literally about 1% of PhDs who
go for they're vipers fail and most of
those people haven't had touch with
their supervisor for like a year it's
very rare to fail a Viper
or you can get corrections minor or
major basically means that yeah the work
you did was up to scratch but there's a
bit more that could be done so if it's
minor Corrections that more often not
just means like formatting of a figure
or some spelling mistakes if it's major
Corrections that means that you have to
do a bit more work and maybe do a bit
more analysis if it's minor Corrections
that generally means it takes a couple
of weeks at most maybe to fix everything
it's major Corrections you're looking at
a couple of months of work then lastly
if you're some kind of Wonder child you
could get no Corrections and you know
one person that had no Corrections and I
mean he deserved it he's a genius but
generally most people aim for major or
minor Corrections if you get minor
Corrections it's the equivalent of like
a stellar result that's kind of what
everybody hopes for really and then
after that you go to your graduation you
wear a floppy hat you get to collect
your degree and you can call yourself
doctor and have that sweet sweet bank
appointment where you go in you say I'd
like to change me on my account for a
mr. to a doctor please is that where
anyone else does their PhD it's kind of
a reason why I'm doing mine and that's
it congratulations you are now a PhD
you've reached the top level of academic
achievement the kind of question of what
you do next is a bit more difficult that
I don't know the answer to so don't ask
me I hope you enjoyed this video it was
kind of cathartic to make makes it seem
like what I'm going to do is a bit less
terrifying if you do have any questions
about the PhD blight process then put
them
there in the comments and if you enjoyed
this video please do give it a like oh
and if you do want to learn more about
the process of kind of going through a
PhD I'm going to be regularly vlogging
throughout this last part of my PhD and
you can come on the ride with me if
you're a but for that if you'd like to
do that then there's a subscribe button
down there thanks very much for watching